for joining us Archer
item one and he said apologies for
absence please
thank you chair well that's the language
that's the law councilor Watson thanks
for craigie thanks for the manly
councilor gov councilman Jones
councilman Brown councilman Dart
Pennsylvania
Stacey and Tom batstone
[Music]
how many people are suffering from this
viruses
item two uh Council minutes of the 31st
of October
I'll run through them
uh Page by Page starting at page four
page four
five
six
seven
eight
nine
ten
percent yeah sorry
um in my report on that to the traffic
um
I mentioned the local cycling and
walking infrastructure plan and
um it isn't actually in here in this
community here and I quite know so you
put it in it's under the Sixth paragraph
down
um
worked out by consultant so the detailed
proposed cycling and walking routes
I'd like to insert as part of the
Barnstable benefit of northern local
cycling and walking infrastructure plan
for lcwhip for sure
[Music]
um
after the post-cycle walking groups
because that was in my report now makes
it clear but back to consultation but
why the
[Music]
um
it's being assumed
okay on the paragraph 10 going down
full consideration in the reports going
with
um I see web consultation and the mass
grass inaccurate and I put in
um
all consideration in the report was
going with the results of the LC whip
consultation please
thank you
okay so it was page 10 page 11.
here we've got the vote
for all the discussion plates so there's
not quite adding up is it in the right
place
where you're doing it
I did read your email and um
I could give it some consideration we
didn't actually come up with a final
answer on that
so just run through that again exactly
what it is your concern with uh because
here the cheaper threat I explained in
part one uh about what we had to where
we went to the part to discussed it they
came back and we voted here we've
already voted before we even got the box
due to an answer so what can decide on
it you know I mean we voted before we
decided
a second
uh I think I understand what you mean
Council bright so are you suggested that
because of its insertion in the military
looks as though it was decided before
he's actually voted upon yeah but this
was the only way of getting it into the
minutes because obviously it was in part
two which is at the end of the meeting
and then we came back into part one
um it was the most practical way of
getting something in the minutes uh to
clearly uh demonstrate the decisions
that had been taken I'm not sure how
members included it that's the meeting
and we can't just say we go back into
part one at the end and then exit there
I guess we could just insert a line to
say this this item came back into part
one following a part two discussion uh
or Amendment for the information to be
included in the open public agenda
something like that says
[Music]
I'm sorry the second paragraph says
following the discussion in part two so
it's already explaining that we've been
into part two
and then the vote was taken so I think
it's quite clear yes
I suppose following the discussion in
partly the meeting we're trying to part
one yeah so I don't like personally I
don't see that it needs any better
adjustments no
okay where were we are page 11.
uh page 12.
on page 13.
I'll move them from the chair five
seconds all in favor of the pre-show
[Music]
um
thank you
item three is the action list which is
on page uh pages will be in the 16.
you can see cancer Haynes another
promotion
the right to the NHS to request
reopening of the minor injuries unit at
Medical Hospital
Ames yes I spent everybody's seen that
so I think it was put in the bulletin
yeah but so it gave no clear indication
that there is any intention of reopening
um obviously there's huge problems in
crisis and the National Health Service
but this is uh this is a real blow to
this area lacking such a service that's
an unfortunately didn't make it before
clear because there was a commitment to
bring that down I'll share your concern
uh and the other one was I question the
Chrissy's notice of motion
but uh
what was obtained figures on South black
water after emergency sewage releases
into the tourist District including
coastal areas over the last five years
and the letter was pursued yep
um
members bulletin I'm not sure how many
of you managed to read it and it's like
wading through treacle
um it just went on and on and on um I
will be raising this issue at planning
um where it comes up quite often
about cancer was water handle all the
new sewage that we seem to be passing
I'll put it that way thank you
that are all waiting to retrievement as
soon as I suppose
okay uh item four public contributions
we have two popular country
contributions or question to speak on
the proposed Housing Development on
South Street Car Park
so we've got Ann tattersall first
so
yeah
okay so you have your three minutes well
firstly thank you for giving me the
opportunity to come and speak here
tonight and I'd like to thank the
following counselors Council bright
Council Carl honkin Ford Hurley Langford
and inch for having the courtesy to
respond to my letter that I sent to
everyone and for those of you who didn't
respond I'd like to just say not only is
it rude and shameful it's totally
unprofessional and why use have a first
commitment to your ward just remember
and be mindful that you were also
elected to represent this District
and I'd also like to highlight
um how difficult it is to have a
communication with counselors I went to
the Democratic service and asked that my
email my letter be emailed to everyone I
was told this couldn't happen there I
had an email back and I'd just like to
say in any fast forward organization we
all know that we have got group emails
and that's just one press and it can go
out to everybody so I'm just wondering
why you make it so honorous for an
ordinary person to reach the counselors
um I was told that um a lot of you
counselors were dismayed by the flurry
of emails that you received from
Warrington and that really surprises me
because our three Ward coins first
fought ferociously told you there would
be a backlash but yet you had the sheer
mitigated temerity to go against their
wishes and you've seen the backlash
and I know I'd like to say you had an
opportunity for affordable housing when
you were presented with the plans for
torrage bail but instead of putting in a
106 agreement and social housing you
held Ransom to developer who told you
that it would be too costly so you know
it's a great opportunity here that makes
me wonder about the intellectual
capacity and the decision making here
I'm not going to bore you with my ladder
because I hope it's a ball read it you
know you've gone against the
neighborhood plan you have assets
stripped Torrington for too long you've
taken away two of our car Parks
um attention quite clearly in the
neighborhood van that this is not
sustainable for our intern if you do
anything with
our car park
and Jeffrey Cox has also told you is
that if you go forward for planning he
will call this
um so what I would suggest is you take
this completely off the table your
proposal off the table
um because it's just not visible and you
know that so why are you wasting
taxpayers money by having a visibility
study when you already know that this
will be called and if it goes any
further I'm sure you'll well over your
three minutes I wish you a happy
Christmas and I hope your conscience
stays working for 223. thank you thank
you
all right I know we've got Richard and
Yvonne Matthews
my name is Yvonne Matthews
and we're not objecting to affordable
housing per se we have 10 grandchildren
in and around Torrington and we would
like them to be able to afford housing
what we are objecting to is the plan to
build houses at South Street car parkour
this is prime land with glorious views
and within walking distance of all the
amenities in Torrington
and so they would sell on for vast sums
of money
it can make them affordable now they
won't be that a few years down the line
when they're allowed to sell they'll be
worth a fortune but once the ground is
sold it is sold forever
we object because this is an
inappropriate use of our car park and
directly contravenes and undermines the
great Corrington local plan
in 2018 the planned Steering group
identified a number of key issues
and as a result of public consultation
and household questionnaires they were
grouped under five themes environment
housing transport and infrastructure
Community facilities and employment
which form the structure of the
Torrington vision for great torrentine
yeah
during the consultation pool behind the
draft plan public transport and
congestion in the Town Center were
raised as key issues
due to the loss of part of news Road car
park and the proposed restrictions on
the street parking within the center
public car parking in the car center is
a major issue
the two existing public car part this is
um section 8.27 of our vision for
Torrington
States the two existing public car Parks
so Street and body growth are essential
to the Social and Commercial well-being
of the town
providing easy access to shops business
churches and other social clubs situated
in the town center and adjacent areas
these car parks are already subject to
volatility in terms of parking numbers
and often reach full capacity when there
are social or Church events organized
furthermore the opening of the town hall
is a venue for weddings and other large
events the growth of tour tourism
the Torrington plans to try to develop
and the continuing increase in
population will contribute to adding
pressure
you're one over time now on the
framework so I know what I want to say
thank you very much
there's lots of other things new
drainage is the major one area
thank you
okay item five uh decorations of
Interest well members who own all the
school there any items to declare is due
to the appropriate time
item six agreement of the gender items
between part one and two we have part
two items this evening I propose from
the chair kind of a secondary all right
sir I haven't did the original agenda
include something about Brunswick mall
the original one may have done but this
one doesn't it was withdrawn
so our proportional Chair seconded by
cancer range all in favor please show
thank you
[Music]
item seven on the agenda consider
correspondence brought forward by the
chair I've got two items um
the first one I'm sure that you you all
share with me in sending our condolences
on our thoughts with uh potential lock
and her family at this Dreadful time and
did never a good time but uh this is
absolutely good for news and I was
really shocked when I heard it so
um we will get a card
presented and would be as many people
many countries as we can sign my quality
um the other thing I've got is uh as you
know councilor Hutchings member for
holdsworthy resigned uh recently and I'd
just like to thank him for the time that
he he told us just to kind of serving
the members of poetry
yeah that's a question
said because when we had the original
agenda there was a very large items with
that one to war you say it's been
withdrawn but has it been withdrawn by
the gentleman who now owns it or by the
officers because this is the real
importance of Industry I mean the only
reason I could think of why it's being
withdrawn is that you signed the
agreement is that correct or not
I'm not aware that I finally win
um
to reply to that
um
come forward on your next agenda for the
30th of January
um it's largely withdrawn uh with the
um
spot of the chair because our head of
legal and governance who needed to
provide detailed legal advice to
counselors is on leave this week and
obviously tonight's meeting is
rescheduled from last week so
um unfortunately that's the case
so moving on item eight the question has
been submitted from cancer Hudson and
this is to answer questions submitted
under procedural rule A9
but my answer has been circulated
Council holder yes
um thank you very much uh I have never
seen such a comprehensive response to
the question
um and to to be fair I have not read
while we were preparing in detail and I
would like time to inwardly digest but
however
no feelings are that my supplementary
question which I'm allowed to do
apparently uh might not be based on
everything that's in this report but to
sum it up it seems to me that we ought
to be looking at our enforcement
budgetary powers
and whether we ought to be this Council
or to be considering and I know we're
saving money in other areas
whether we really ought to be looking at
setting aside
some funding to be able to take some
action to be able to remedy some of
these issues within our communities
because these are major issues
that our communities actually report to
us and complain about and it is it's
constant and that was why I wanted a
response to explain to them exactly
where we stood
but I think my supplementary would be
that I would like to bring this forward
on a future agenda at CNR
uh I don't know if I'm allowed to do
that
in response to this or whether I have to
bring a notice of motion any responsible
to me
yeah
the rules and uh A9 questions you only
ask a supplementary question directly
related to the the subject or the
question you've asked already we can't
ask for something just to be written
agenda in lights of your uh submitted
question right well my supplementary
question is where is the budget to take
these actions that you've outlined
hmm
okay we will provide a response
separately thank you very much
National laws
yes
on this this subject because this isn't
up for discussion no
may I just ask is this open to the
public can I publish the whole thing
what was the public are here tonight
yeah
we will publish this on the west with
our website because it showed the
frustration for award member in sapo and
it appears that Tories are doing nothing
I know you've tried but yeah you must
have some tea for sure thank you
okay item nine petitions uh there are
none
item 10 local council tax support
abandoned income scheme ages 17 to 31 uh
37. some daily days yes
I'm probably pleased to know there is a
small presentation
[Music]
model shelter yeah you'd be pleased to
know there is a small presentation
so
ideally the local council tax support
scheme should be reviewed on a regular
basis a previous proposal to mender
scheme of 2016 was rejected by elected
managers the impact of the coveted
pandemic on the workload of the revenue
benefits team then delayed a further
review
so what have we proposed and what did we
go out to consultation on well we're
proposing the introduction of an
incombanded scheme where depending upon
the income of working Aid claim and say
based into one or four bands where they
will receive support to our 75 plus
percent
200 of their council tax liability the
base of the principle has been adopted
by many councils across the country I
would also proposing to remove the
non-dependent deduction so Jessica
members benefit and non-dependent
deduction is where somebody an adult is
living in the house in say full-time
work and we would reduce the local
council tax support to take into account
that they've got non-dependent who's
working and contributing to the finances
of that household we would retain the
band D limit and the six thousand pounds
Capital limit
I would introduce a minimum income flow
for self-employed people in line with
Universal Credit regulations with
basically it's 35 out of the national
minimum wage
so what are the advantages of the
proposed scheme well income Bandit
scheme based on set bands of income will
help to con the contained Administration
costs as we reduce the number of
reassessments that native take place
it'll be simpler for our customers to
understand and easy for them to budget
our significant reductions in their
bills will be regenerated removing the
non-dependent oxygen also reduces the
ministry of burden and also aligns with
Universal Credit regulations next slide
please um Kirsten
so
so we we employ some Consultants got a
policy and practice to model uh proposal
this scheme is projected to be
essentially cost neutral so if that
means it's cost neutral for ourselves as
time it's all called what that's equally
important it's cost neutral but our
um be set to colleagues such as um Devon
County Council
that are into it about 1 650 people of
working age who claim local council tax
support
under the proposed scheme as modeled by
the experts in the field policy and
practice only two households would lose
support completely
85 percent of working age claims would
received at full 75 support towards
their council tax liability
101 household can see their support
reduced by over five pound a week while
155 householders gained more than five
pounds a week and those lose in a
primary self-employed people on Legacy
benefits and there's a table below which
I won't necessarily go through
um but it shows the thresholder which
people get support
so what this graphic is trying to do is
trying to explain the benefits of Bandit
skiing you see there at the bottom a
roller coaster at the moment every time
somebody's income changes and we get
notified about it we've got to do a
reassessment of their account or tax
liability and we have to rebuild them
the polls have abandoned Steamers it's
only when it goes the roller coaster
goes below above that middle Blue Bar
would we then have to send out a revised
bill so it makes it more certain for our
customers that they know within a
certain range of income they're not
going to have their council tax
liability change and be rebuild clearly
as well it reduces our burden in
administration next slide please
so the impact of the proposed changes
which I've already alluded to you can
see there
it doesn't really change a lot for most
people 75 well of our customers the vast
majority gets 75 of support and the
figures on the right hand side show
those who came or five pound and though
they've lost more than five pounds or
two bars on the right hand side of the
chart next slide please
so we went out to consultation and what
did the results of the consultation tell
us well it's largely told us that the
people who went out to consultation with
approved with the scheme and the bar
charts that you can see there see levels
of support from just under 80 to about
60 for the various questions that were
asked so you know first one do you agree
with the intro to an income bonded
scheme and basically 70 of people said
yes and you can go down that list about
things like dependent children Etc and
I'm not sure it's on the next slide just
comes in that slide please
it's not but I think how many
consultations did we get it's in the
report so we've got 186 people actually
reply to the consultation which may not
seem a lot but it's actually an
exceptionally High number for a local
equipment Council consultation that's
unusually hard
so the recommendation before you is a
full Council approve the instruction of
an income bounded scheme for working age
recipients of local counter transport
with the intention to go live on the 1st
of April 2023
in the absence of capital resources we
believe we've got capital resources
lined up for January 2023 uh we didn't
plan the policy from the 30th of April
2020 but in the absence of that we'd uh
we want full Council approval to
implement it from the 1st of April 2024
we don't have the capital resources in
place I think at this point I want to
hand over to councilor Hudson
thank you
um yes I'd like to as part of the
working group we've spent uh pre-covered
uh lengthy discussions where we were
almost at the stage to come to full
council with a report but everything
conspired against us we reviewed it the
situation hadn't changed in any ways and
I think that the committee that that
well the working group that met together
were fully supportive of introducing
this scheme so tonight I it gives me
pleasure a long last
to actually uh make the recommendation
that we do approve the introduction of
the income bonding scheme
and secondly that if it cannot be
implemented because of uh the software
issues that this is carried forward to a
new Council and it will be implemented
in April 24th so I think it's important
that we put a mark down now to say that
we are committed to this
so thank you very much
endorse what has been proposed and to
say
as has been said that this benefits of
claimant gives greater security and
Surety to the claimant is easier and is
less burdensome to administer it's cost
neutral and I would have propose it
though thank you for a calls that's been
seconded kind of the Shelf has in
support at least
interesting
Anonymous thank you thank you David
[Music]
thank you Joel as well but um the um
item 11 council tax base for 23 24 pages
38 to 40 on your agenda and once again
it's David Hayes was at the report okay
I don't seem to go through the report
line by line and I've got an
unfortunately for you there isn't the
presentation
um just so everybody knows Tommy's
council is required to set a tax base
it's a statute of responsibility with
her in very simple terms it's activated
the number of properties liable for
council tax within forage at the end of
November so we take a snapshot of the
account the properties that arrival for
Council taxi end of November and then
with that figure we make some
adjustments
so we're just for discounts so for
example a single person discount if you
live on your own in a house you only pay
75 traffic Council so we make an
adjustment to that we make an adjustment
for things like the awards of local
council tax support that who just
alluded to and then we make an estimate
with colleagues from the council tax
team about new properties that will come
online during the course of the next
year and then we make an estimate of the
reduction for non-collection of council
tax these figures are then converted as
required by Statute into Bandy
equivalents as required by this you know
qualified rules so the tax base
following this meeting which is in the
reports
um will be formally communicated to our
preceptors which is Devon County Council
uh Devon and Somerset
fire
Devin and Caldwell Police and I am from
56 town and Parish councils which rage a
precept they need this tax-based
information in order they can carry out
their budget set in so the
recommendation is in the report there is
to approve the touch base as detailed in
the report happy to take any questions
at this juncture okay
it doesn't look like anyone wishes to
ask a question a proposal for I propose
that's going to propose second midline
councilor Clark all in favor please show
you know it's easy David honor rolls
Tennessee dude
that's dangerous
thank you
right the next item is a gender item 12
updated proposals of the member budget
working group ages 41 to 47
in your agenda I think Council
commissioner and David Hayes are going
to do this together yes
I don't have my back to anybody this way
and I can look at the screen
but okay so just before counselor Hudson
speaks uh in the report it refers to an
appendix a free money application for
false charges for some reason probably
my error we won't actually improved the
report that's what's been handed out and
um on your desk today
okay that's just to let everybody know
like
right I I appeared before you
weeks ago with a report from the member
budget working group
um and I have the pleasure of returning
uh with the latest findings of the
member budget working group so we have a
short presentation for you so if I can
have the first slide please no
no given the meeting to have a financial
strategy there
right don't worry about it we will
ad-lib uh I have it in front of me
uh you'll remember that uh back in
February 2022 we established a member
budget working group to come up with
proposals to bring the council's budgets
back into balance and the group was
subsequently approved by full Council on
the 13th of April
the remit was to the group was to
minimize redundancies proposals should
be deliverable within a reasonable
framework prioritize raising additional
income over cluster services and the
work of the members working group should
continue for the life of the current
Council
well I'm just about alive but I have
been uh teetering I think the members
working magic group reported back to
full Council on the 5th of September and
made recommendations with regard to car
parking charges access to the boroughs
members Grant discretionary business
rate relief Garden waste council tax
premiums
and treasury management policy now all
these were approved and put forward all
these proposals were approved by you
um so the figures which you should have
had but are they embedded in the report
yeah
basically
so basically what we improved on the 5th
of September improved the council's
budget by 23 24 by 479 000 pounds and by
2026-27 improved the council's finances
by 704 000 pounds which is not on
infinitely pre-quarters of a billion
pounds
so so far so good that we realized that
there's still work to be done
um and in addition to finding the
current additional income Savings of
250k it was tasked with finding cash
savings of 350 pay to facilitate the
setting of a balanced budget for 23.24
uh David as usual with his wonderful
um
gave us a picture of the low uh hanging
fruit that we've gathered and perhaps we
needed to be reaching a bit further up
into the branches to harvest some more
suggestions
so the members working group looked at
Cemetery charges
might seem a bit strange but
um Cemetery charges historically have
been a reduction for local people at 50
percent
and it was decided that we could
actually reduce this to 25 percent
so because at the moment the 50
reduction doesn't even cover the cost of
providing the service
so with a reduction to uh 25 discount we
would actually achieve 28 000.
an increase in pre-planning application
fees as detailed in the report would
generate an income of 45
000.
and a revised methodology for setting
business rate appeals provision as
detailed in the report releasing one-off
additional income of three hundred and
forty seven thousand
in summary recurrent annual Savings of
Circa 73 000 and a one-off cash
releasing Savings of 347
000.
next steps members of the working group
are going to review the Java Financial
settlement which this Authority uh
is received just received today so we
haven't had time to actually examine
that and examine how any funding Gap
identified at this juncture can be
addressed
my recommendations to you today are the
recommendations in the report
um and to note that we will be meeting
again on this the 6th of January 6th the
6th of January
and this one was working through will
welcome anybody who wants to attend the
meeting to make it known that they'd
like to attend this meeting
um and they're more than welcome to come
and we will listen to all
uh so the recommendations of the report
are
to approve the reduction to the resident
discount for Cemetery Charities to 25
percent
to approve the increase to pre-planning
application advice as detailed in
appendix a
and to agree the release of previously
improved Capital pids as detailed at 2.5
now I'd like to propose these
recommendations but I'm
need to be able to ask anybody got any
questions
I've got one question if I right the um
the pre-planon applications
whilst on the face of it I I agree with
most of them the um
the small minor and other charges
currently a hundred pounds you're
proposed proposing to put them up to 220
and that was
120 increase which you know for anyone
that's putting in a very small
application
uh on our property that seems to be
a really really big increase you know I
mean it depends how you view it I mean
these are the charges our neighbor
employers have been charting for several
years now also the other thing is this
is
discretionary they don't need they need
to do a free planning advice you can put
in a planning application without using
our service account or you could use
um specialists in the market to give you
this advice you know we're in the market
against the private sector for this
advice so it is up to the individual
concerns to see what value they put upon
this and as opposed even a small
extension Republic is probably 20 grand
now so I suppose they'd have to wait up
against that kind of Outlook do we get
very many individuals
ask for a pre-app meeting yes there's a
significant number
fine
okay anyone else got what's going on Ken
Chad yeah I'm just going to pick up on
on those
um I'd just like to record our thanks to
Hannah Smith who actually put a lot of
work in to do this including uh looking
at what entrepreneur the council's been
doing within Devon so it is
um you know is a solid base those
speakers compared and if I take up on
the pre-run you know you can save
yourself thousands of pounds paying a an
agent to tell you what our officers will
tell you for a hundred pound or 200
pounds so you know it's a good deal
um and so I just like to say that and to
record my time to say hello for the work
she said
thank you
did we have a Honda thank you
so
um
please support these measures I would I
would just like to take this opportunity
to say though that something like
um re-planning advice fees where we
we're told in a brief but and we are
behind North Devon and we are constantly
looking at other people we always seem
to be behind and should we not be more
proactive in reviewing our charges on an
annual basis or whenever
um as opposed to constantly running to
catch up with other people and of course
by the time we actually Implement these
North Devon would have put theirs up so
we'll be behind again anyway
um and um so I would have thought that
there is a wider message here that
perhaps we should be more proactive in
reviewing our fees to make sure they are
up to speed and
um are relevant
my other comment would be on Cemetery
charges I support what's in the
recommendation here but I would ask and
suggest that on another occasion we do a
separate review with Northern and oh
sorry on uh on Halloween Levy Cemetery
charges I would have thought that the
majority of people in the district can
easily pay full charges whereas actually
a relatively small number of people
ought to be it should be actually having
a much greater discount than 25 at the
moment it's very basic it's it's one one
one fits all whereas most people should
be able to pay the full fee and those
who really need that the help or can't
afford it should be actually getting a
greater level of relief is what I would
say that's another day but I propose
perhaps that officers may choose to put
that into the thinking part
um doctor I just respond to the first
question from Princeton new church so uh
the piece of all the piece and charges
are reviewed on an annually annual basis
and are reported to community resources
as part of the the budget process uh so
without going back looking uh back at
previous meetings and previous decisions
it may well be that members previously
decided not to increase uh certainties
of charges as sometimes happens so
um we often compare with neighboring
authorities and authorities across
across them
comparative purposes but uh they're
dealt with on an annual basis and
something going forward to giving
resources on the 30th of January and
that um 2023
bye you can and then I'll bring cancer
very briefly I think
um the exercise that the members budget
working group has undertaken has
afforded a small group of people to Deep
dive into all our fees and charges
um and ask for comparative information
and I think this is what is actually
highlighted some of the areas that
perhaps in previous years we haven't
felt the need to explore so far
um and I think that is why we've come up
with what we have and I I think the
officers and the people who've actually
been looking at this in examining these
and having a really good look at what we
are charging thank you
okay thanks
thank you Mr chairman before page 45
foreign market
this I believe the listed building
if Joe blocks or president Smith wrote
in the district have enlisted building
they can't afford to maintain
our planning department will be on the
left on a breaks
and yet here we are to say we're not
going to spend money on our listed
building
but cannot be run
get the chief executive to answer that
um
if you if you recall in a previous full
council meeting uh you approved uh
heading in all the works to the Pioneer
markets to be funded over the rural
shared Prosperity fund alongside
abundant for Victoria Park so this is an
old scheme and uh subsequent funding has
been put in place for that listed
building and Council I've seen it would
definitely got a favorite pair
um assuming the the funding comes
forward we've just had announcement of
the shared Prosperity fund and we are
waiting uh confirmation of the
allocation of the rural shared
Prosperity fund so they're all coming
out
um in a in a sequence
it will be kept before that the money
has arrived
the money hasn't arrived yet because the
it hasn't been announced but we are
expected to be announced shortly
foreign
[Music]
future we can look at targeting pannier
Market the same way as a bit of a
Pioneer Market was handed over to the
tank and so they can run it then ceases
to become a burden on
power resistance Council and would
benefit probably Target in a far more
but uh coaching Newton did you have your
hand at that no because I hope sorry
but yeah that's not my area but I know
fairly well among Snow Line kill
um are we are we satisfied with this lot
of danger to the public as president
tradition
yeah yeah
so there's been some emergency Works
undertaken there recently they're
drawings are closed now
um and yes once those have been
concluded it will be it'll be a much
safer environment than it previously was
and that's why we did it because it
become very very dangerous
new chair let's see uh 106 is mentioned
in this report and we um looked at
Community infrastructure and levies at
all we do we charge them if not one
um
we looked at that so so we've never
um well the community infrastructure
Levy was considered some time back uh
and we never implemented the scheme to
introduce a community infrastructure
Levy there are talks of uh reforms to
the planning system that would look at
infrastructure levies so it probably
wouldn't be timely to be looking at that
right now
all in support of this piece
[Music]
okay
and against
any against on the abstentions
as well thank you
[Music]
we're kind of moving all joy to the 13.
that's an update of the medium turn
Financial strategy ages 48 to 57
and once again
yeah apologies
again uh there is a presentation
so
that's obviously concise and not dampen
the mood of the room too much so a ball
counts on the 5th of September will
present we've been updated lead intern
Financial strategy the pertinent point
to the report on the bitter September
were
projected over spend for the financial
year
2022-23 of one just over one million
after repurposing reserved to the value
of half a million pounds essentially I'd
overspend to 1.5 billion and this
compared to an underspended 2021-22 with
1.7 million so obviously can't turn
around
the main drivers in the Council of
advert financial department be the cost
of celebrating the council
responsibility towards the equation to
risk of homelessness
and inflation perfect everybody here is
fully aware of employers ours was the
salary of the pay settlements fuel
utility costs Consortium price inflation
um and at that time the council
transitioning government Reserve would
be heavily depleted and contact Council
wouldn't be it would have difficulty set
in a balanced budget for two government
324 which is why you tasked the event of
budget working group to continue its
work
um next slide please
so that's the just this slide is you've
seen this one before but I just wanted
to reiterate it aspirin knowledge and
responding to the financial pressure
Space by the inflation The council's
Limited in what we can do not like the
supermarket there we see Rising input
prices have just passed onto the
consumer we cannot do that the council
tax referendum recently announced is
five pound or three percent whichever is
the greatest of which so it's three
percent so even on your countertop by
three percent business rates we do not
set the rate in the pound and we do not
set the actual value business done by
the valuation in central government
government grant we literally got the
settlements uh today which we're
currently digesting but we get what
we're given essentially so please
enchantments so only about half of the
fees and charges are non-stattery notice
or for example planning is statutory we
don't determine that cost
so there's only full freedom on 19 of
our income
next slide please
so what's changed
well there's been a measure of
improvement the council's financial
position the challenges let's be honest
largely remain the same
the council is facing unprecedented
levels of expansion Central
accommodation means responsibility as
well as residents at risk of
homelessness the projected 2023
expenditure on temporary accommodation
is circle 1.3 million and the growth
expended to the council including
housing benefit is 16 million so that
shows the scale of it there's a chart
there at the bottom shows what we spent
in previous years and my mouse isn't
great
but I'd imagine if you might be it isn't
great
yeah that is [ __ ] alive however you
end up with four blues figures I think
they only just come to more than the red
version so the last four years we've
been last four previous years we're
going to spend more than them in
Combined next slide please
Okay so
we've got an updated deficit here
excluding the environmental status
customer we'll come to it later so you
got in blue where we were and in I'm
going to say orange
yeah where I think we are
and the side at the bottom of the table
at the bottom shows the transitioning
government fund reserve and as you can
see previously Ms far Captain would be
overdrawn in 23 24 and the overdraft
just carried on and on whereas now okay
we only really dip into the overdraft in
26 27 so it is an improvement in our
figures uh next slide please
so what's changed since the last mtfs
interest rates continue to climb
so that means we're getting increased
income on our treasury management
deposits our shorts
and the council tax we've got a surplus
for Broadcasting Service for this year
2022 100 000 pounds which we can only
access next year in 23 24. also the
council tax referendum limit has
increased slightly so it means we'll
raise another 9k in 23 24 but by 26 27
that'd be another 63k
um the business rate income as Council
Hodgson alluded to in the member budget
working group we've changed how we do
the business rate appeals and that's
released as a one-off 347 000 pounds and
there's been some reassessment of the
ink we can expect renewable energy
schemes but they are still estimates
guesstimates
uh there's a separate agenda item on the
Environmental Center so the costs are
presented exclude 170 000 pounds
previously in there so just add that as
a marker in your minds but whilst it's
improved let me taken out between the
costs next slide please
uh external audit fees which is a this
is a painful one for us to take
so in conjunction with 99 of our
eligible bodies storage opted into the
public sector appointment bodies
procurement of external audit Services
we'll actually let the tender accessing
and snipping increase in RDP reflecting
both the increased regulatory
environment we work in and wider
resources say capacity issues in the
sector while definitive costs have not
yet been confirmed we've been sold to
expect an additional cost 150 so that
equates 125k per year from 2020 425 so
so no added benefit to the council we're
going to incur additional costs 125 000.
I think it mentioned in the report that
the public sector already made
representations governed to try and get
what's called new burdens funding for
this
um I haven't banks on that and I'll be
surprised if that came about where I
could be wrong
insurance we renew our insurance
contracts in September every year and
unfortunately because it's in that's
linked to inflation since September was
about 10 percent
also an additional certificate element
of our contract is linked to the cost of
rebuilding properties and in the event
of Fire and Blood so a construction
crisis being so high refilled costs have
risen and consequently sold the
council's insurance agreements so the
additional cost is about 56 000 pounds a
year that's why please
okay
hostile most modular accommodation
increasing cooking costs Rising interest
rate that they've just alluded to I've
had to update the financial benefits of
securing hospital for publication
having still it's a no-brainer
financially to secure hostile
accommodation however the financial
benefit has retracted by 56 000.
the member budget working group has made
recommendations which we've just
approved in terms of 70 charges and
increased pre-planning application fees
and they've improved the financial
situation that's fine please
so the mcfs compiler can pass I'll start
to go the mcfs includes those assumption
risks and caveats and the most personal
which are I've made the Assumption
council tax Will Rise by three percent
Crown appreciate of the mutant Financial
structure that's clearly a decision for
elected members
I've made assumptions with our hands
girls how quickly will deliver the
hostels for modular accommodation but we
see any slip between that well in part
time dursley
the council is exposed to interest rates
both in terms of the infinite receivable
short-term pressure deposits but more
importantly it's borrowing costs
future inflation pay utilities
conscription I can only estimate
and also the number of renewable schemes
and the Business rating that we'll
achieve from that that's an estimate
and later report the cost Associated
delivery of an environmental center
uh also put your Grant settlements from
Central Portland like I said we've just
had literally today the settlement from
central government which we're digesting
but even so
um
a lot of it's one year only so I don't
know what they're going to do the year
after
um I don't know I've had to make
assumptions in the underlying growth in
the business rate base and the council
tax base
and also because of the issues we have
with homelessness and the temporary
accommodation one of the big factors is
the status of the privately rented
accommodation Market
so there's a roundabout way I'm trying
to say don't blame me if I've got it
wrong
um but there's lots of risks and
assumptions in the presentation I've
done too you know we are in a very
difficult environment next slide please
[Music]
released today not tomorrow uh members
decision about the environment Center
the employers pension review we just got
through the figures um in the last day
or so pressures and save his identified
managers during the budget saying we're
coming towards the end of that so we've
captured most of that and further
indication of a likely pay award for
23.24.
the updated mtns I'll be following the
local government settlement but I've got
the employer's pension information now
the budget setting with managers is
concluding
um but we'll be updating that and that
presented at the members budget work
group on the sixth of January which is
Council of Hudson has said he's open to
all and so in conclusion clearly her
work will be acquired from the member
budget working group of remain alive the
discounts on of the life of a new
Council this is like it's involved
significant reviews of Service delivery
there's increased income from fees and
charges there's a lot of people who've
been maximizing unfortunately because of
the presentation of the slide you did
see a really good slide about low
hanging fruit which we've largely
Harvest Food you just have to imagine
that I'm afraid I think that's my last
slide yes it is happy to take any
questions but I think it is just for
noelson
it is just a note in but uh okay
um thank you for that uh slightly
worrying that you can't do the math but
um
uh about business rates because we're
all aware that um we're charging extra
council tax on holiday lets and second
homes and so on and there's been another
one announced today I see in Devon but
the point is the people who own those
can afford it
um and we're seeing more and more
they're reclassify themselves as
businesses and therefore paying no tax
at all uh what I cannot get my head
around is that if you've got a domestic
property and you reclassify his business
that is a challenge of use under
planning and yet they never come to us
are we following this up with rmp
because this is becoming a major problem
in the whole of the Southwest that we
are losing Revenue we are is it all
right I know I think I have asked this
before that are we bringing this up to
our MP because they do need to do
something about this
okay I'll respond if you're like uh
coach Christie yes we bring it out
regularly
um and it is you know included in the uh
um
regeneration bill so it's include in
there around the registration scheme and
uh implications around change of use
under planning so it's interesting it
became part of the bill
um and obviously when it becomes
legislated assuming it does become
legislated uh there should be means and
ways of managing the system better
thank you I just hope it's a Pity it
can't be retrospective but you know
okay well thank you David we know that
moving element your item 14 yeah just
get a glass of water you surely can't
you shut me down
foreign
Management on residents to Pages 58 to
69
your agenda
it does say uh Peter Hudson but David is
going to do this and say yeah
okay and there's two components to this
report actually and we've obliged
foreign
yeah
yeah so we're obliged to do as a
mid-year debate on our surgery
management so we've got static
obligation to do this report for you
um however there is a separate item
about resonance which I'll I'll go
through in a little bit more detail so
let me just do the normal statutory
update on the um treasury management
well you can see everybody knows
interest rates have risen you're in 2020
to 23. that's had a significant impacts
on the returns we've had from our
investments so we're forecasting we're
going to get 340 000 pounds our interest
on us in short-term Investments and that
was compared with fourteen thousand
pounds in a year 21 22. we still have
high cash balances are reported
um needs to have some caveats to that
Air Max reserves which we've got for
future Capital spend lastly their cash
back that's money we've set aside in
previous years so that we can spend
future capital
we have some central government grant
funding primarily now to do the cost of
living crisis so what we've got
um which we aren't necessarily utilized
which is over and above in the past that
would be covered pandemic type grants
and also at the time of year we have
quite high balance risk because we
receive the majority of our income from
council tax in
10th through the year and spend or in
12s because people play calstuck over 10
installments
uh previously ball Council on the 5th of
September including some changes to our
charity management policy that was a 10
million pound limit on placement of a
single financial institution and a 5
million deal size
um peer-to-peer lending and one million
pound massive investment 250 000 any one
particular scheme we haven't done any
peer-to-peer Lending
so that's just the update that's in the
report which I would be doing every year
just to statutory update however there
is something that we need approval from
Members today so a leadership and gave
permission for opposite of the council
to submit a bid to the Department of
Lebanon
um and this scheme was well a company
called resonance which is not the profit
organization to deliver
10 one value properties within solids
for which we would have nomination ranks
um we were successful in that funding
and the way the scheme works
is that the department of Labyrinth were
provided 500 000 pounds we provide five
hundred thousand pounds and socially
minded investors provide 500 person so
1.5 million in sold as I said to deliver
10 one bed units throughout Torrid for
which we would have nomination rights in
the first instance it would be here to
Russ slimmers in the absence of roughly
because we could use its utilizer for
our existing residents at risk of
homelessness and in return salaries
would receive a return of three percent
on the 500 000 pounds each invest and
three percent on the department of
leveling UPS investment so I've given us
an effective rate of return of six
percent which is well that's better than
anything we've got currently out there
on the market
and we've got the added advantages of
these 10 properties for rent within
storage at local housing allowance rates
so the treasury management policy does
need and there's a recommendation in the
report full Council approval to include
resonance as an approved counterparter
essentially somebody that we have lent
money to have to take any questions
as the planet unfortunately thank you
thank you very important just to aspect
residents
um the 1135 investment under the
homeless scheme this priority need only
the house by the local Authority is the
restaurant scheme will widen that
description to host people or are we
going to take people off our housing in
households
here to book sleepers they're absolutely
yeah but the the department 1100 if you
don't have
sufficient for sleep is you can utilize
it and leave your housing or
homelessness need within the world okay
thank you very much
but we don't have a sufficient number of
rough sleepers we can utilize a health
plan
thank you
Council James I'm just happy to go into
recommendations
um including open to the second one the
first one for the mountain
second ones we approved the 500k to
Renaissance
um
as David said if we haven't got the last
seepers we can start working on our
homeless people and we have got several
schemes underway on that right second
number
Country Newton
okay well it's been proposed yeah
um I think they knew this are they going
to go on to the land we're looking at is
it Tori's land they're not being put on
no they they'll just search the market
to find suitable problems
okay so then propose a second of our
councilor Clark all in favor please show
that's unanimous okay thank you
so moving on to item 15 member
allowances ages 70 to 71.
thank you
all right thanks Jay so a subtle change
from David uh thanks for all that
um so member allowances uh the short
report
um you may recall in previous years when
we had the independent member
remuneration panel reports to council
and members accepted that report and
accepted uh in normal circumstances that
members allowances be increased in line
with the increases to staff salaries
which is fine uh in normal circumstances
but in this Current financial year staff
salaries have been increased across the
board by
1925 pound as had been agreed uh between
the employers and unions
um so an increase of that size on member
allowances would be somewhere in the
region of uh 35 30 six percent uh which
I'm sure it all consider quite a high
percentage uh we included in the
council's budget uh two percent increase
for staff salaries and a two percent
increase for member allowances based on
the fact that they would ordinarily
increase uh on a local like basis
now what many councils have been
using in the absence of that General
increase is the increase in allowance
General allowances which has been
applied to other languages which is
4.04 percent so that's been included in
your reports as an option and is that
there's a table in the in the report
there for you to consider
um I've also included in the report the
what the average would be across all
staff salaries of the 1925
1925 pounds uh which as a percentage is
6.9 perhaps
um now obviously you'll note there's no
recommendation from me in the report
um because unevitably it's up to members
to determine the the level of increase
or otherwise to your allowances uh happy
to take any questions if there are any
um but I'll leave it open then tonight
councilor James let his hand up first
and then counselor Brenton thank you
chair
um a slightly corny one
um I can hear the justification for
every different percentage depending on
however you look at it it would take
um that's a human's point about not
getting behind others but getting right
um we know that the London powers on
block have accepted 4.04
um last week
and I was in North Devon it was eluded
that they will probably go from the 4.04
as we said that we originally when we
were doing the budgets we looked at two
percent
um but given the circumstances
I find it very hard to justify any
um and so I would recommend we went for
the third one not to increase the
analysis this year bearing in mind it
will possibly slip us behind but I've
studied every single
pay structure within the whole of Devon
and there is no single pattern because
it depends on whether it's executive
whether it's a committee or full
um a fourth optional Council
and also the variation tends to come
with responsibilities more than with the
basic pain our basic pay is very similar
and slightly better than a lot of other
council's basically pay but once you
start moving up
um it is quite illness okay it looks
like there's just a second being a
number in some cases but having said all
that I should probably be the lowest
paid one in college in the top Tavern
that's not an issue I just think given
the circumstances given the struggle
that people are doing and this chairman
of the um the budget working group and
told me I'll probably have to find some
cuts to cover it I will propose that
allowances stay as they are but as far
as I'm concerned my group will make
their own decisions those with not
um there is no pattern to it
my second day
well the Casual Brenton wanted to speak
person
thank you well it comes to Christy being
me too I would probably second uh your
hand up first
I'm not worried about that
um in the circumstance of the area that
we live in the level of deprivation Etc
that we know about all the time we see
at all time you know it would be really
insensitive it would say the very least
for us to even consider living in our
allowances are
certainly the view of those of us that
met earlier
okay
I need to repeat I agree entirely what
councilor president
I I would likewise
um agree that we should freeze our
current plans thank you
I'm not disagreeing I just wanted to
raise a point that if we want to
potentially diversify our Council there
is a possibility that not everybody can
give their time for free so the idea
that you don't potentially increase it
could have an effect on that that I can
clarify that I'm fully in support of it
saying the thing but I just wanted to
make that point more as a consideration
thank you and that is a really good
point and that was actually discussed
earlier on this afternoon
um Council Hudson brought the point up
so I'll just ask ask her to reply that
all right thank you very much
um yes this was one of our reciprocals
it was one of our considerations that
leader was going to add two of his
recommendation
that uh we started process of looking at
allowances not the the fixed amounts but
the recompense we give people
um who have to uh arrange for child
minders
the the mileage
um which hasn't been increased for I
don't claim it so I'm not sure when it
was last looked at and evaluated people
who have lose a day's work or have to
take a day's holiday because the days of
employers saying oh yes you work for the
local Council or you're a counselor if
you do have the day on but it doesn't
happen anymore so we have to recognize
the fact if we want to encourage a wider
representation from our communities we
need to consider these things and uh I
would like to add that to the
recommendation that we keep
um our allowances as they were but we
look into and examine
um
the other ways of
um recompensing would-be counselors
thank you thank you thanks range thank
you chair well you know
next year I think it's an election
coming up listener but there's not
something to do with the recommendation
being
um recommended you know that we don't
get anything
um I disagree really we have a budget
here of two percent
and
um you know they did this on Devon
County Council
they didn't raise their allowances for
about six years
and when they finally did it came out to
about 10 or 11 percent which caused
uproar in the in in Devon and you know
it's the same old problem isn't it we
didn't raise our council tax for a long
time and looks relaxed on us and Steve
we have to keep Pace everybody has to
keep pets and I think
um a two percent rise that's what we
budget that's what's in our budget and I
think if we split the difference and
have a two percent Rider that would be a
fair and honest way to go down Rule and
I I propose a honeymoon
Mr Pennington just check the governor
website but uh employees can ask time or
for uh public duties and that is
enshrined and long so it's there and
that's why we get relevances so it is in
government UK websites along with other
public
members of committees that may be the
case but a lot of people working part of
an Enterprise and it's not the case in
private Enterprise no
I'm just pointing out the law that there
wasn't made clear by our Deputy yeah
without one of them is that law doesn't
apply in private Enterprise
for employees Pastor Brian sorry on that
point I can just tell you that my
employees and that will be the time off
but I have to make that time up so I
have to just put Glory time from
somewhere else in my life and make it up
again
I get lost but they don't have to do
they just you know agreed to me do it
they're very good to allow them but most
important yeah the proposal as
cancerologians laid out is eminently
sensible did you want to speak yeah I'd
just like to
um apologize to councilor Pennington for
getting it wrong and I wasn't referring
to public sector workers or I was
referring to those who have been working
with us
and work in the private sector or are
self-employed and those are the people I
was alluding to so it is looking at a
wider representation from our community
being able to join us
have a secondary yet for your Amendment
from Memphis
I would suggest that we look at it in
the new year yeah and just deal with
what we're dealing with though I think
that would be more sensible than trying
to get in a model I I think you know and
it would we won't do nothing we will
come in the next uh next until
um so we can start it going
um we can do a notice of motion or
whatever it needs just to get it started
just to look at and what I would say is
when I did look at every single payment
to every single cancer in the whole 11
there was different allowances for
different things so it isn't consistent
and there's a question of what we do
look at you know do we need to do
something
um and kind of punisher's point is I'm
not sure that public sector workers can
be members of an elected Council
I just made the point in response to
what's on the government day website
thank you
um uh what you used to be alerted right
at a reasonable time or do Google
cultural work yeah
[Music]
um
I'd just like to say you know the idea
of looking at individual circumstances
and paying for individuals is not a good
idea at all we Amalgamated the Broadband
child news Etc into our analysis is
about three more years ago
that is making life far sooner when you
start going into individual charges
there were more Administration costs I'm
sure to do that and it also creates a
discrepancy between someone like you say
who hasn't got children so I'm not
paying their child care whether it's to
someone who has got children who is
paper child care who that will get a
further allowance for that
counts or inches points as well is um is
a good one we always talk about you know
people not coming into the councils and
being a council because the race is paid
if they don't increase the allowances as
we go along they step so far back you
end up in a situation where you've got
to put a large figure on there to try
and bring it back in to kill them
I'm not increasing charges the public
out there are some well done counselors
that's very good of you in these time
trying times because it allows we look
out here it's not a huge amount top 100
pounds a year or whatever
um and even if we do put it up for that
there will be some criticism but there
always is we do that all the time so I
think we should go along with the four
percent
just to keep in mind with them
you know depicted like inflation so a
certain degree otherwise you're going to
end up falling so far behind no going to
want to do the job because they're on
the other 40.
thank you Josh
is that a proposal
yes
right okay thank you so we've got a nice
second
councils yeah
uh kind of syringe you didn't have a
second or for your two percent increase
did you well so I have the draw my
careful sure okay so did I see a hand
come up here just out of it
I'm just going to say it then
first of all the proposal made by the
leader
it's for this year because this year we
have exceptional circumstances I think
Council range was talking about six
years or something that Devon County
Council didn't react well I would fully
hope that by next year the situation
will be improved and therefore we will
feel more relaxed at actually putting up
uh our allowance
um secondly the the allowance is just
that if we want to use the allowance to
attract people into being a local
councilors and local government in other
words we want to pay them a rate where
they can actually afford to do it when
they're not doing something else we're
going to have to play a whole lot more
than what we do at the moment and there
is that there is no suggestion of that
neither is any budget for that and I
after a while if you're being paid then
you start to move away from doing
something as a local public
representation and it all becomes you
start to populate a different Persona uh
and I'm not quite sure we particularly
want to go there because it's a
different different Beast so I wouldn't
agree with my colleague here
um and I agree with the The Proposal of
the leader
Woodhouse pray for me um I just wanted
to make a point
when we talk about counselor allowances
I'm not talking about people cashing in
I'm talking about them covering the
costs of them being here to make it
helpful so everybody has the same
opportunity it's not it's not
necessarily about walking Castle again
just about them being able to cover the
cost specific to them to be able to
attend themselves yeah that's a good
point and that will be covered further
in the New York certainly with your new
character yeah
here comes someone host
um and just saying
when you are age or my age anyway and
reasonably comfortable
I don't know how to support my
grandchildren I don't have to pay for
somebody to the bathroom but if you're
in that position those people they're
using their knowledge to do Council work
to cover costs that come about because
they're doing parents work and I'm not
saying what's right and wrong I'm just
saying let's look at it in the spring or
International Airport let's see whether
there is an issue that and so that just
younger people we're not going to pay
the wage we don't employ them but what
we don't want them to be is
disadvantaged and I think that's the
main point I want to make
thank you chair okay shall we
we had a proposal and a secondary but
there was also an amendment uh and it
suggests that amendment is is taken on
by the budgetary worker group so we take
that into next year so and today are
withdraw the amendment right okay
so we've got a proposer that we maintain
the status quo with a zero
take a vote on the amendment uh to
include Council Hodgson proposal
yes
right so it's been important for a
second is that we maintain the status
quoles in other words there's a zero
percent increase in member allowances
correct yeah has been proposed and
seconded all in favor and support of
that
and again
and abstentions
oh that's clearly caring we'll point to
any other one that attacks
[Music]
okay moving old angel item 16.
notices of motion we have won the
resolution from councilor Brenton
uh councilors can present another
solution arrayed up to three minutes to
explain that and I'll call for a
secondary it was also around three
minutes
Council Brenton thank you
what kind of services I asked you to put
aside my uh polling record at uh
Publishers motion what do you think as
it's Christmas
um I think you've read it uh it's it may
have ripped you off your feet a little
bit but I think we live in radical times
which offer radical measures to uh
alleviate them and tonight we've got a
few more interesting pastures to go on
the business of the homeless and we've
got more sleeping plasters in the
pipeline as well but we do need I think
to look at what's coming our way and
it's about to hit the county and you
know what I'm talking about it's getting
quite serious now over the question of
accommodation
the very fact that our home secretary
who I don't try to listen to very often
at all but I did she did actually
mention it in one of her speeches about
cruise ships being used for
accommodations and there again I heard
the Scottish national nationalist uh
homeless home
um housing Minister also talk about it
well you understand
but it is feasible I believe I don't
know I've done much homework but I own
the fact of the model internet and see
how they are scrapping perfectly good
accommodation because there is no demand
for it we're in a unique position in so
far as we do own little dog which has
got quite a good birthing uh situation
there bearing in mind that over the
years the the shipyard had brought out
um some vast vessels and park alongside
there
clearly it needs a lot of work attached
to this it may be an ideal thing for an
intern or an apprentice to do some
homework on that and also to contact our
neighboring authorities I've spoke to
the housing
um uh person on extra city council and
she didn't Express an interest but you
know that's what he writing yeah so I
would ask you at least to have
somebody look into this as a possibility
or has he been bearing in mind also that
the Ukrainian refugees are coming to the
end of their six-month um period of
being with host families and I do know
that our families who would like them to
find somewhere else to live and that
isn't going to be easy we don't have it
do it we've got no Airbnb you name it
we've got all sorts of things uh
inspiring to stop people getting
accommodation so I do think we should
consider any possibilities thank you
thank you Cassie Brighton well you've
heard the proposal would anyone like to
Second this
uh our second deal
okay but I do have just a couple of
things to say that's all right the idea
in principle because I like to stand up
was a particularly see my beautiful
figure okay the idea in principle is
very good and I was standing out to
Brown I had thought about this and
spoken to others about it in the past as
my role of lead member for homelessness
um the major concerns are when you put
lots of people in tight accommodation
like that you've got to think
of what diseases or illnesses then can
happen do we have the right
infrastructure for doctors nurses which
we have a major problem with anyway you
know and you also got the social aspect
so in principle
I was second out of England's idea but
it does need a lot of work and you've
got to spread it out because there are
other things you know if you put people
in there who possibly have alcohol or
drug issues so it's not it's not an easy
fix some people might think oh yeah we
can do that what cruise yeah fun loads
of people in here we've solve the
problem no you've created a problem that
we didn't have before so you just got to
think it through properly okay
just to invalid something that
um
um councilor Brenton said and that
Scotland have been using container I'm
sorry not content um cruise ships to
accommodate Ukrainian refugees as they
came over initially as a Holding Center
and then when they could be found
um permanent accommodation then they
moved out it's a difference there and
going very much along the line of what
council Clark just said that was a
single focus group who were
um socially were going to mix well and
easily together uh and whilst they came
with many traumas they were unlikely to
create other issues whereas
um
there are quite clearly many other
different issues as Pastor Clark
inferred when you do that right there
is a good one
it's thinking out of the box and from my
background we've used this type of
accommodation around the world many
times in the past because you can sail
up an instant hotel and you can
accommodate people on it so it it's been
used many times in the past where you
put it how you do it is a completely
different game but the idea of thinking
out of the box it it's it's worthy
goes to Christie is the last speaker on
this item thank you
um yes well when I saw this first let's
suspect suspect that I had the same
feeling that many of us had that this
was slightly you know practiced but
having said that I think it is worth
looking at
um my issue though is that I used to be
in the Merchant Navy and the big problem
with ships is maintenance and I think we
need to approach our Harbor Master we
need to approach Capital Shipyard just
to ask about this because it could be an
ongoing cost that is so high as you rule
it out but uh yes by all means let's
look at it
okay must be proposed a second agent I
think I'm allowed to sum up as a
proposal
yeah
thank you
actually uh leave a lot of us hostile as
I thought it was going to be but never
then however
um as I say it's really
get some mechanism to look at it and and
get some research done because although
I take the point about pushing people
all together in tight proximity and it
could cause problems us debonians get on
pretty well together actually I don't
think we've got a problem with that so
um
hospitals do have warrants in them as
well so you know it wouldn't be some
pseudo Vision it would need some
planning of course it's it isn't going
to be easy but the point about it is it
could have done quite quickly if all the
problems are iron damage so um it's up
to you
thank you
okay well it's been proposed and
seconded by councilman Park all in favor
or in support please show
thank you
okay
[Music]
okay
and again
hmm
and abstentions
oh that motion is clearly carried
about it
okay there's no needs item 17 and 18.
to move into part two can have a
proposal please can I say James second
to my
because holds it all in favor please
show
this is where we say goodbye to all
friends in public
join us on YouTube and I take this
opportunity of wishing you all a very
happy Christmas and a Happy New Year